من بيل جورد الى مضيق البوسفور في تركيا
تقول الانباء ان رقعه الصراع بين موسكو
وكيف تتسع صراع ان صح ما يقال فانه لم يعد
حبيس الحدود الاوكرانيه والروسيه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت عن تعرض احدى
سفنها لهجوم بزوارق حربيه وفي منطقه خارج
حدودها الاقليميه امر يجعله اول هجوم من
نوعه خلال الحرب الاوكرانيه يقع خارج حدود
الدولتين
الهجوم وقع على بعد 140 كيلومترا شمال
شرقي مضيق البوسفور في المنطقه الاقتصاديه
الخالصه التابعه لتركيا واستهدف الهجوم
سفينه ايفانخورس التابعه للبحريه الروسيه
في تمام الساعه الخامسه والنصف فجرا عبر
ثلاثه زوارق هجوميه مسيره عن بعد موسكو
اتهمت كييف بالوقوف وراء الهجوم اتهام لم
تقابله الاخيره برد حتى اللحظه على خلاف
الهجوم الذي استهدف بيلجو الروسيه حيث نفت
اوكرانيا صلتها به
وفقا للدفاع الروسيه فان السفينه
ايفانخورس تقوم بمهام ضمان سلامه عمل خطوط
غاز التيار التركي والتيار الازرق مؤكده
ان الطاقم السفينه تمكن من احباط الهجوم
وتدمير الزوارق المهاجمه
بعد الهجوم الارهابي في السادس والعشرين
من سبتمبر على خط نورس ريم تتخذ القوات
المسلحه الروسيه تدابير لحمايه هذه
المرافق سفينه ايفان خورس التابعه لاصول
البحر الاسود تواصل اداء المهام الموكله
اليها
قرن زادت موسكو من اتهاماتها لاسيما بعد
حصول الاخيره على اسلحه غربيه نوعيه
اتهامات لا يعرف الى اين ستتصل واين ستاخذ
الصراع معها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات